quel est le plus gros délit que vous
ayez commis vous autour de la table
guillaume genton à part bien entendu
j'ai volé des mouvements comme c'est si
c'est ça l'histoire bon ben ça va et
alors venir répéter away équipe avec
jean marc bonnet plein et je faisais
crois que c'était pour plein de gens
âgés manger tout seul voilà vous avez
vous êtes attrapés pour moi bien sûr
alors qu'on défonce et mes bas mes
parents et je me suis pris une gifle oui
mais seriez il a volé de dragibus on est
comme ça entre la peur qu'il ya une
brigade car il prit la baule et de
dragibus à 45 on est comme ça les gars
ça c'est un truc de fou de pino alors
moi c'est un sujet un peu tetch hisser
dans le monde du travail en fait jean
remis à lundi ouais je vous ai fait en
fait je suis parti en vacances sans
demander l'autorisation
pas longtemps ça c'était vraiment super
hyper cheap pardon
la limite du délire la punta cana vous
avez passé l'eponge oui
bob l'épongé peuple est faux bien sûr ça
y est c'est plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
c'est terminé halak s'est terminée à
déterminer d'alpine ça y est c'est
terminé nous amène pardon et rapide
quand ça fait trois mois que ça dure
alors oui raymond alors de l'aider ni à
cause de vous dans ma vie moi tout seul
bouger 30 de garde à vue c'est vrai j'ai
fait sinon ils vont vous et moi tout ça
le plus gros délit vraiment où je me dis
je ne suis pas très fier je veux avoir
13 14 ans et en fait on démarre et des
voitures il est tournevis à l'époque il
y avait une marque de voiture qui s'est
pas moi qui vais moi j'étais à côté
passager toujours
été le tour de vis
aussi démarré avec le tournevis les
bonnes idées de marque de voiture vous
pouvez démarrer ces délais des voitures
comme ça et on allait on allait en cours
avec la voiture en fait et ça c
est pas bon du tout est en fait on était
dans une colère on est vraiment qu'on a
cherché les mecs par tout ce qu'on sait
peut-être volé une autre voiture
votre match où on a cherché pendant des
journées entières qui nous avait volé
une autre voiture
et ya volé des questions l'a pas volée
qui va s'y
prendre la caisse m le tournevis partir
à l'école et ne plus retomber la rupture
si bonne et la quête gdpl a démarré nous
on s'est dit que si on a le droit de
daniel aussi le débat
après c'est avec vous les autres plus
grosse et on a volé des bus ensemble
matin
c'est la grève va voler un but 100
mètres les jambes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'ici c'est minable celui qui
donne l'ordre aux élus qu'il exécrait
presse et reculer il a dit non
finalement c'est une mauvaise idée en
avoir des problèmes aucune et leur à
bordeaux alors mais ça peut être drôle
et moi j'ai dit je vais le faire le
faire et après johnny web a dit chez
nous
midi entière au commissariat de la
garenne-colombes dirait il est là le
commissariat m'appelle moi je ne connais
pas cette île je suis content j'ai
appelé hanouna eelv a désarmorcé vous
allez voir
c'est franchement c'est inadmissible ce
qu'il appelle est puni c'est le cas mais
comme ils le méritent et dacquois
mathieu vous avez l'air dégoûté a volé
une voiture
il regrette il l'a dit mais si vous
saviez ce que j'ai fait quand j'étais
jeune d'ailleurs j'ai deux amis
d'enfance qui sont dans le public si
vous saviez ce qu'on a fait c'est une
dinguerie vous avez deux amis d'enfance
âgés de 2 ans mais je ne savais même pas
qu'ils étaient là ils sont là bas c'est
jamel et rachid deux amis d'enfance avec
qui je raconte ma vie du courage merci
son nom vient tirer à si bon bien sûr et
francs par mois et son fils ait connu
merci oui c'est même pas vous qui le
rappelle une des places et je sais même
pas qui venait à waimes pas je savais
aussi ces mêmes objectifs
non mais j'ai fait des trucs de dingues
- avec toi et par exemple et il m'a mis
en dans un carrosse de fort boyard une
caisse à savon de fort boyard pour
traverser des champs elysées toute la
matinée autour du rond point des champs
elysées avec une caisse à savon j'ai
fait me faire percuter par un camion
trois heures de garde elle a vendu des
animaux en avant lui déplaire on aller
dans les restaurants et puis je voulais
vivre
4 et a payé en cash on s'en souvient
j'en ai fait des gardes à vue moi j'ai
fait passer pour un rossi pour un très
gros c'est entre apple aurait dit moi
très gros criminelle ah ouais mais
c'était ça c'était génial parce qu'en
fait je l'envoyais dans un café je
l'envoyais dans un café c'était
extraordinaire cachez le dans la
n'auriez gens qui arrivent je les
envoyais j'ai envoyé dans un café fort
ça c'est précieux je n'en voyais dans un
café et chapelet le café et je dis
bonjour henry
commissaire broussard
de la d re pcj de lombez pourquoi on
nous a signalé un individu très
dangereux au sein de votre établissement
hindi est ce qu il portait une casquette
rouge c'est là oui on voit une personne
est quelqu'un ce n'est une casquette
rouge au bar et de la turballe méfiez
vous est-ce qu'il a commandé un papayou
l'ailé
il me disait il me demandait de randa
pape a eu un jeu voir papa lui oui oui
vient de commander
[Applaudissements]
bien d'autres cachés dans la cave cacher
le dans la cac est-ce que je peux bien
sûr à cavaler zisapel commissariat du
17e à l'époque pour faire vraiment qu'il
y avait un mec qui foutaient bordel dans
le café des flics arrivent et tout mais
moi comme un con je rigolais jusqu'à
temps que je me fasse embarqué
m'avait bien dit que je regarde a vu
encore et ça c'était ça c'est tout un
repas ça moi je sais dit moi je
t'avais garde à vue mais c'est génial le
principe d'envoyer un mec en garde à vue
tous les matins
le principe mais également tous les
matins vous l'avez aussi bas oui oui
bien sûr mais bon bah là bas tandis les
héritiers j'étais fier celerity bah oui
c'est à dire c'est d'héritiers enfin pas
sur tout mais
sur les vannes sont des
moments que je suis pas d'aller retirer
entendu oui j'ai cherché chez des
enfants
ou des biens des mois j'ai squatté des
maisons j'ai tapé des gens avec des
barres de fer
et des prix s'est jamais lassé que la
voiture et lycées
m elle ne referait plus mais j'ai tapé
fort
j'ai injurié des gens c'est ouais c'est
vrai mais bon j'ai rarement été pris par
rapport à tout ce que j'ai fait de mal
et aujourd'hui je vous assure je suis en
pleine rédemption tout va mieux aussi
répondu rassurez-vous décédé mais j'ai
mieux géré ma colère c'est mieux gérée
par des gens parce qu'il le mérite est
imposant des on se tape à coups de barre
de fer
là commence à cambo à quoi à qui at one
foot crois qu'on tapait les ans coup de
barre 9 avec 10 ans d'avancé voile était
un trawniki strappé des gens face
j'étais rappeler les anciens mérite à
l'éthique mais personne ne réveillez pas
la colère je les gère
[Applaudissements]
sarens en foutez côté là
tu vas attendez attendez dans deux
minutes daniel juliette a fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
daniel
qu'est ce que vous avez fait non mais je
cherche pas très bien j'ai volé un petit
un petit cadre avec un acteur que
j'aimais bien dans un bar en face d'eux
il ya peut-être encore le trou
d'ailleurs j'étais
dans ma chambre est grave s'écrie
l'acteur jean pierre darasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la mairie paraît que le mec le mec quand
il a vu qu'il avait disparu la loi pas
fait la [ __ ] d'arras
[Applaudissements]
c'est halak heures exceptionnelles jean
pierre barat ces
championnats a pris 0,99 bien sûr oui tu
te casses les castanics vous avez fait a
parfois pas la polygamie
une étoile des canadiens
thaïlande des
barres de fer et va te casser la gueule
kg fait de plus grave ce n'était pas en
france j'ai falsifié des documents de
pilotage j'ai piloté ne vais pas là les
sensations n'étaient pas très loin mais
j'arrête ça madame non
[Rires]
et
là d'un cas tourner dix chansons
cela mérite qu'on s'y croirait écoutez
babel 47 merci oui vous aviez des gens
avec vous comment non il ya vous voyez
mais moi il y avait moins de rester tout
seul mais c'est très con passer devant
quid du peuple belle 47 je suis sûr
qu'ils avaient une mafia
japonaise je connais castany va pas
refaire un tour en hélico tout seul
il a voulu gérer le bois cubain luis est
conduit en
faites pas ça s'excite aliens
[Rires]
les